I'm sure that you've heard that a plane
crashed and Coil Berry
kill
early 21st century
today,
our fellow citizens,
our way of life,
our very freedom came under attack in a
series of deliberate and deadly
terrorist acts.
The attacks on nine 11 not only shook up
in nation,
but they woke the entire world from a
decade of relative tranquility.
After the end of the Cold War,
the data towers fell would mark the
beginning of a political scientist,
Samuel Huntington coin,
the clash of civilizations,
the West versus the rest.
Now what are you resonate with?
This concept is up to you,
but he most certainly did.
Either you're with us where you are with
the terrorists
and in the war against terror.
It's this frame of mind that will
reaffirm American identity and its role
in the world dramatically.
So I think the 2004 puppet sets higher
team America will police does a great
job in depicting this proposed American
view of the war on terror.
The story is about Acthar and spy and
Gary Johnson and his counter terrorism
team as they take on terrorists
worldwide wide.
And ultimately you have to confront the
biggest terrorist of all the late
dictator of North Korea.
Kim Young,
ill professional,
James Gow argues that the film reflects
the of this realists interpretation of
international relations.
Now what does that mean?
Constructivism is basically to clean.
That's significant aspects of
international relations are historically
and socially constructed and not the
consequence of human nature.
Realism on the other hand,
can be thought of as unified by the
belief that rural politics ultimately is
always and necessarily a field of
conflict among actors pursuing power.
Now if you're thinking,
I don't understand this at all,
don't worry,
the film was a brilliant job in
explaining the basic gist of it.
There are three kinds of people,
Dick Pussy,
pussy take,
everyone can get along and takes,
just want to fuck all the time without
thinking it through.
But then you got your ass check and all
the assholes.
One got shit all over everything.
So does a little bar room wisdom about
sexual relations actually turns out to
be the most important scene of the movie
as it's ultimately what saves humanity
from nuclear annihilation.
The more importantly it lays bare to
films,
philosophical core,
the decks in the old man's story,
our team America,
and an effect.
Everyone who acknowledges and support as
America's assumed real life role as
beliefs force of the world.
The all American white and blonde team
represents the hyperbole of patriotism,
dressed in American flag combat gear,
and moving around in a similar style
vehicles.
The team operates all over the globe
with a well known American bravado when
the sense of optimism,
their self confidence in their rule as
self,
a clean police of the world.
There's also their main weakness.
Although the team is effective in
stopping terrorists around the globe and
it's often crude and clumsy methods,
they end up doing more damage than the
terrorists themselves.
[inaudible]
Damn,
I missed him,
but it would be false to say that the
movie is enzyme American.
On the contrary,
you to characters who publicly opposed
to team notably to members of the film
actors guild or arguably made fun of the
most met
the members of fag or the policies of
the word.
They don't believe that violence will
sub terrorism and don't want America to
act as a police force of the world.
However,
as the old man pointed out,
who sees our only one and a half inches
away from the assholes,
and indeed in a criticism of team
America,
the actress slowly started to turn into
terrorists themselves.
The hassles of the movie art a
terrorists and Kim Jung,
Il,
they don't care about anything but the
destruction of modern civilization.
And all of these characters are
portrayed and overtly stereotypical way.
In a Alaria segment,
the team give Gary and quote unquote
elaborate makeover.
So blend in with the terrorists.
Now you would expect to see a new person
as he comes out of the surgery,
but instead he returns with some brown
paint on the skin and pubic hair on its
face and its whole resembling a turban
on his head.
The joke reaches its climax is gary has
to pass to Garza without raising any
suspicions.
Buck,
Dirk,
dirk or la?
Okay.
Durka Durka Mohammed Jihad.
Yeah.
Oh,
darker.
Darker,
darker
in North Korea.
Kim Jung.
Il speaks broken English and lives in
the city of Chinese takeout boxes.
Wait,
a round ring.
Oh Man.
All of this reinforces the
constructivism president in the film.
The way the world is portrayed as the
way America chooses to perceive it,
and it's this red or naive view that
causes the team to have so many enemies.
However,
Gary does realize in the end and chooses
to come to terms with it.
Maca can definitely do better in their
role as world police,
but they're constructivist.
Realist view does triumph and although
the actors don't wish to accept this day
to ultimately see violence,
it's the only means to protect her own
values.
We can't look weak and powerless.
If violence is all those bastards
understand that violence they'll get.
So despite all the heat,
you American managers to dismantle a
cumulus,
devious plan and save humanity from
certain night.
Elation as philosopher and Admin Berg
once famously stated you only thing
necessary for the triumph of evil is for
good men to do nothing.
Or as the movie like suits explain it.
I don't know much in this crazy,
crazy world,
but I do know that if you don't let us
fuck this asshole,
we're going to have our dicks and are
pussies
all covered in shit.
It's this sense of pragmatic realism
that writer and director,
Trey Parker and Matt Stone are trying to
convey.
It's you.
America won't beliefs and quiet.
Paradoxically it seems that's the
America's goal to prevent and destroyed
terrorism all around the globe will
never be finished.
Their view of the world means that there
will always be a new terrorist in new
enemy to fight.
And so far to the theory seems to have
rung true in real life as well.
But in the NTU America doesn't really
care about what do you think their dicks
and as long as there's assholes in the
world,
it's all be Dick's willing to fuck them
again and again.
Okay.
All right guys,
thanks for watching.
I hope you enjoyed the video.
There's a couple of things that I
quickly want to talk about.
Uh,
so first off,
as I'm recording this,
we've just surpassed 2000 subscribers
and we honestly couldn't be happier with
how things have developed over the last
couple of weeks.
Uh,
we never fought.
We gain so many followers in this short
amount of time and we want to thank you
all so much for supporting us and
spreading the word.
It's,
it's good stuff.
Now,
a lot of you have been giving us
constructive feedback on their work so
far.
Uh,
it's mostly people saying that we sound
a lot like the nerd writer did that we
want to say that.
Yes,
we do to an extent and honestly,
uh,
I don't actively try to do so.
I think it's mostly unconscious and just
the way that I personally like to do my
voiceover,
uh,
I think set that we're both trying to
move away from that a little bit and I
believe with time our own personal voice
will start to shine through more and
more.
Secondly,
you've tried turning down the volume on
the background music a little bit,
so I believe that shouldn't be an issue
anymore.
Thanks for pointing it out to us.
Finally,
I want to invite all of you to follow us
on twitter and facebook as we will be
posting updates on our channel and media
related stuff.
So if you want to stay up to date,
definitely check that out.
That's about it.
Thanks again for watching and see you
guys in the next one.